For the Danish listeners that are currently listening to this podcast, I do apologize once again on behalf of Bryce. I would never say such a blasphemous thing while in Denmark. The commonwealth press makes me think, is there a relation to replicate, in particular the second overload and run-length encoding? We're going on a boat that is not a boat, but it looks like a boat. You're likely to die from a...
对于目前正在收听本播客的丹麦听众，我再次代表布莱斯（Bryce）表示歉意。在丹麦，我绝不会说出如此亵渎的话。英联邦出版社让我思考，是否存在一种与复制（replicate）相关的关系，特别是第二个重载和游程编码（run-length encoding）？我们要去坐一艘船，那不是一艘真正的船，但它看起来像一艘船。你很可能会死于……
I don't want to say a cyclist. I'm from a cohort of cyclist. I almost died multiple times. I think we could just take one of these boats? No. Should we take the ferry? No. Well, why not?
我不想说是骑自行车的人。我来自一个骑行群体。我差点死过好几次。我想我们能不能直接坐这些船中的一艘？不。我们应该坐渡轮吗？不。好吧，为什么不呢？
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 255 recorded on September 20th, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we record live from the streets of Copenhagen. In this episode, we talk about multiple implementations of the replicate algorithm, Denmark, boats, and more. What's the name of this street? It's right there. You try to pronounce it. Congenstorv. I'm going to say that was probably like a five out of ten.
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，这是 2025 年 9 月 20 日录制的第 255 期节目。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯在哥本哈根街头进行现场录制。在本期节目中，我们将讨论复制算法的多种实现、丹麦、船只等等。这条街叫什么名字？就在那儿。你试着读一下。Congenstorv。我觉得我刚才读得大概能打五分（满分十分）。
You would get a one. I would get a one. I'm not saying I wouldn't get a one. All right, we are here in the beautiful city of Copenhagen. It is 9.24 p.m. on a Saturday. We are in-between speaking engagements. We're just finished up two days. One in Arhus.
你会得一分。我会得一分。我不是说我不会得一分。好了，我们现在在美丽的哥本哈根市。现在是周六晚上 9 点 24 分。我们正处于两次演讲活动之间。我们刚刚结束了两天的工作。一天在奥胡斯（Arhus）。
Orhus. Orhus. At the Roku Engineering Symposium. And then the next day we came to Copenhagen, and we spoke at the Copenhagen C-Bus-Bus meetup, which was pretty great. I think we had great audience interaction. Yeah, you're shaking your head. What am I doing wrong here? You've got the flattest introduction.
奥胡斯（Orhus）。奥胡斯。在 Roku 工程研讨会上。第二天我们来到哥本哈根，在哥本哈根 C-Bus-Bus 聚会上做了演讲，那次活动非常棒。我觉得我们与观众的互动很好。是的，你在摇头。我哪里做错了吗？你的开场白太平淡了。
Don't you remember when we were on the road in Slovenia? Every single time this would happen, you'd be like, all right, we're back. Listen, folks. Hey, it's 924. I am tired. Weak sauce, folks. It's also 924 for me. And guess what?
你不记得我们在斯洛文尼亚的时候了吗？每次发生这种情况，你都会说，好吧，我们回来了。听着，伙计们。嘿，现在是 9 点 24 分。我很累。太弱了，伙计们。对我来说也是 9 点 24 分。你猜怎么着？
I'm fired up. We're live. back, technically not on the road, from Copenhagen, Copenhagen, Copenhagen, and Danish. And let's start walking. Let's start moving. We're on a famous street. We're on the water.
我充满活力。我们正在直播。回到哥本哈根，哥本哈根，哥本哈根，丹麦语。让我们开始走吧。让我们开始移动。我们在一条著名的街道上。我们在水边。
People are out and about. People are drinking. I am also drinking. It seems to be a party city, because the last two nights I have noticed a lot of people everywhere. Out of the bars, hanging out, chilling. I don't know if it's a special time of year. Should we walk this side or this side? That side's quieter.
人们都在外面活动。人们在喝酒。我也在喝酒。这似乎是一个派对城市，因为过去两个晚上我注意到到处都是人。在酒吧外，闲逛，放松。我不知道现在是不是一年中的特殊时期。我们应该走这边还是那边？那边比较安静。
Now, we should walk on this side. We should walk on the phone side. You can't talk without the mic in front of your mouth, Bryce. I understand. You should have gotten two mics. I have two mics. I'm not traveling with two mics. Anyways, listen, folks, we're fired up.
不，我们应该走这边。我们应该走手机这一侧。布莱斯，没有麦克风在嘴边你没法说话。我明白。你应该带两个麦克风的。我有两个麦克风。我旅行时不会带两个麦克风。总之，听着，伙计们，我们充满活力。
I'm fired up. Bryce is a little sleepy. He's a little tired. But we are still in the land of the Danish. We talked about the rankings. We're not stopping at the hot dog cart. If you want a snack, we've got a snack after. Okay?
我充满活力。布莱斯有点困了。他有点累了。但我们仍然在丹麦的土地上。我们谈到了排名。我们不会在热狗摊停下来。如果你想吃零食，我们之后再吃。好吗？
We're recording. If you were hungry, you could have picked up something when I got the beer of Denmark. Listen, folks, I've got a Carlsberg. I've learned many things since coming to Denmark. We love Denmark. It is the country of Jonas Vingegaard. I knew that Pagacha were talking about the tour to France, folks.
我们正在录音。如果你饿了，你本可以在我买丹麦啤酒的时候买点东西。听着，伙计们，我有一瓶嘉士伯（Carlsberg）。来到丹麦后我学到了很多东西。我们爱丹麦。这是乔纳斯·温格高（Jonas Vingegaard）的国家。我知道波加查（Pagacha），我们在谈论环法自行车赛，伙计们。
I knew that Pagacha was from Poland. For some reason, I guess it's because I've never visited Denmark. So whenever I learned something about a Danish person or a Danish thing, I just don't remember it. But I've been to Poland many times. I've been to Vrotslav. Actually, I've only been to the airport in Warsaw, but I'm in to Krakow.
我知道波加查来自波兰。出于某种原因，我想是因为我从未去过丹麦。所以每当我了解关于丹麦人或丹麦事物的信息时，我总是记不住。但我去过波兰很多次。我去过弗罗茨瓦夫（Vrotslav）。其实我只去过华沙的机场，但我去过克拉科夫。
I've been to Poland many times, but never been to have. It's true. I've been to Rotslav two or three times. I've been to Krakow once. I've been there three or four times. Anyways, the point being I know things about Poland. I knew absolutely nothing about Denmark other than Copenhagen was the capital. We talked about this before. We didn't know about Orhus.
我去过波兰很多次，但从未去过……这是真的。我去过弗罗茨瓦夫两三次。我去过克拉科夫一次。我去过那里三四次。总之，重点是我了解波兰的事情。除了知道哥本哈根是首都外，我对丹麦一无所知。我们之前谈过这个。我们不知道奥胡斯。
And we're fired up. We're excited. We are also excited to be walking and talking. Do you think we could just take one of these boats? No. We're walking past. These aren't just boats. These are ships.
我们充满活力。我们很兴奋。我们也很高兴能边走边聊。你觉得我们可以直接坐这些船中的一艘吗？不。我们正走过。这些不仅仅是船。这些是大型船舶。
And I don't know why Bryce would have that thought. But it's definitely not possible for the two of us to man this. I know nothing about boats, and definitely not these boats or ships. What was I saying? Right, the beer of Denmark I didn't know was Carlsberg. I knew, you know, Heineken is Dutch, and Moretti is Italian, and Stella is Belgium. I know a lot of things about a lot of beers. Didn't realize that Carlsberg was Danish.
我不知道布莱斯为什么会有那种想法。但我们俩绝对不可能操作这个。我对船一无所知，更不用说这些船或大型船舶了。我刚才在说什么？对了，我不知道丹麦的啤酒是嘉士伯。我知道，你知道，喜力是荷兰的，莫雷蒂是意大利的，时代啤酒是比利时的。关于啤酒我知道很多。没意识到嘉士伯是丹麦的。
Jonas Vingegaard is Danish. And Denmark is now the soon-to-be owner, a land of the biggest, what is it, DGX? Superpod. Jensen was here, shaking hands. Yeah, I was talking with the wonderful folks of Symbian last night when we were at the meetup. You just mentioned that. The talks were awesome. The folks that were awesome. There's a tweet online showing me pouring. I don't know if it was Carlsberg. It was probably some other kind of Pilsner. It might have been Tuoborg. I've seen that around here a lot. Anyways, so we're fired up. This is going to go on the list of places we've recorded. When was the last time we walked and talked? Was it Venice with Rob Leahy? no it was not venice with rob lihi it was in new york city but maybe also with rob liegee we did walk no no maybe we just recorded in a bar there yeah i'm trying to think because we we were in new york i think we were on the street i think we were on the street the listener will tell us if yes if you count the transition from adobe i don't want to say hq because it's definitely not HQ, but, like, the Adobe New York offices with Sean, uh, we, all New York offices can be considered in HQ.
乔纳斯·温格高是丹麦人。丹麦现在是即将拥有最大的，是什么，DGX？超级计算机集群（Superpod）的国家。詹森（Jensen）来过这里，握手。是的，昨晚我们在聚会上和 Symbian 的那些很棒的人交谈。你刚才提到了。演讲很棒。那些人很棒。网上有一条推文显示我在倒酒。我不知道是不是嘉士伯。可能是其他种类的皮尔森啤酒。可能是图堡（Tuoborg）。我在这里经常见到。总之，我们充满活力。这将被列入我们录制过的地方名单。我们上次边走边聊是什么时候？是和罗伯·利希（Rob Leahy）在威尼斯吗？不，不是和罗伯·利希在威尼斯，是在纽约市，但也许也是和罗伯·利希，我们确实走了，不，不，也许我们只是在当地的酒吧录制的，是的，我在想，因为我们在纽约，我想我们在街上，我想我们在街上，听众会告诉我们，如果，是的，如果你算上从 Adobe 的过渡，我不想说是总部，因为它绝对不是总部，但是，比如，Adobe 纽约办公室和肖恩（Sean），呃，我们，所有纽约办公室都可以被视为总部。
Fake news. Adobe HQ is in San Jose. We know that for a fact, folks. Anyways, uh, we recorded with Sean, but then I think at some point, either going to, I think it was going to Adobe offices, we were in a cab, and then we transitioned from the cab to the elevator to a room. We technically, there was a little bit of walking there. We never start to finish, did a podcast while walking in.
假新闻。Adobe 总部在圣何塞。我们确信这一点，伙计们。总之，呃，我们和肖恩录制了节目，但后来我想在某个时候，要么是去 Adobe 办公室，我们在出租车里，然后我们从出租车过渡到电梯，再到房间。我们技术上确实走了一点路。我们从来没有从头到尾边走边录播客。
talking but we are now we got a lot of people they are people watching and they're staring at us they're probably thinking what are these guys doing it's a little bit awkward folks a little bit awkward i wanted to walk on the other side and brice said no and now people are staring at us the other side the other side is the quieter side do that again the other side is the quieter side oh i see uh i mean i know i said no to dessert but i'm reconsidering oh we're going to get by car we're not getting we're getting dessert we're getting it after We're not taking a dessert break right now. Scott, it's like, it's like, I'm basically with a child here, folks.
聊天，但我们现在正在这样做，我们有很多路人，他们在看我们，他们盯着我们看，他们可能在想这些人在做什么，这有点尴尬，伙计们，有点尴尬，我想走另一边，布莱斯说不，现在人们盯着我们看，另一边，另一边是更安静的一边，再做一次，另一边是更安静的一边，哦，我明白了，呃，我的意思是，我知道我对甜点说了不，但我正在重新考虑，哦，我们要去买车，我们不是去买，我们要去买甜点，我们之后再去买，我们现在不休息去吃甜点。斯科特，这就像，这就像，我基本上是和一个孩子在一起，伙计们。
He sees ice cream and he's like, Mommy, can I get the ice cream? It's like, no, we're doing something right now. I declined dessert at the restaurant. I declined dessert at the restaurant. That's your own fault, something like a child would do. And then five minutes later, they want what they said they didn't want. I'm going to pass. We're going to be healthy today.
他看到冰淇淋就说，妈妈，我可以买那个冰淇淋吗？就像，不，我们现在正在做某事。我在餐厅拒绝了甜点。我在餐厅拒绝了甜点。那是你自己的错，就像孩子会做的那样。五分钟后，他们又想要他们刚才说不要的东西。我要放弃。我们今天会保持健康。
You already, I told you to give me a healthy snack today. And this guy brings me a chocolate chip cookie that has a bunch of pistachio cream on top of it, and then the whole thing is coated in chocolate. It was the least healthy thing I can imagine, but it was very good. By definition, if the whole thing was coated in chocolate, it didn't have patasio on top. It had patachio. But there was sascio was on top of the junk. I feel like for perhaps digressing from important things that the listener may want to.
你已经，我告诉过你今天给我一个健康的零食。这家伙给我带来了一个巧克力曲奇，上面有一堆开心果奶油，然后整个东西都裹着巧克力。这是我能想象到的最不健康的东西，但它非常好吃。根据定义，如果整个东西都裹着巧克力，它上面就没有开心果。它有开心果。但开心果在垃圾上面。我觉得我们可能偏离了听众可能想要了解的重要事项。
No, no, no. This is important, folks. Before he said, get me something healthy, he said, get me something savory. And so he gave me two different instructions. And, you know, which one are you supposed to listen to? The one that you think Bryce actually wants, or the last one? But you got, you got, I asked for them in savory and healthy, and you got me a cookie. Oh, yeah.
不，不，不。这很重要，伙计们。在他让我买点健康的东西之前，他说，给我买点咸味的。所以他给了我两个不同的指令。而且，你知道，你应该听哪一个？你认为布莱斯真正想要的那个，还是最后一个？但我得到了，我要求它们是咸味和健康的，而你给我买了一个曲奇。哦，是的。
Savory crepes are the ones that don't have, like, chocolate sauce. They're the ones that have, like, meat inside of them, right? Correct. All right, I did mess that up, folks, a little bit. I did mess that up a little bit. Hey, listen, it's not on me. I was lightheaded. I was low on calories, and he's lucky he got anything, folks.
咸味可丽饼是那些没有，比如，巧克力酱的。它们是那些里面有，比如，肉的，对吧？正确。好吧，我确实搞砸了，伙计们，一点点。我确实搞砸了一点点。嘿，听着，这不怪我。我头晕。我热量不足，他能得到任何东西就算他走运了，伙计们。
Anyways, we're talking about Denmark. We were talking about the folks at Symbian. Shout out to Jens, Nina. What? You said something about them getting the world's largest DGX SuperPod or something like that. Yes, I discovered that last night. And anyways, Denmark, I love Denmark. It's honestly, is it my favorite Scandinavian country?
总之，我们在谈论丹麦。我们刚才在谈论 Symbian 的伙伴们。向延斯（Jens）、尼娜（Nina）致敬。什么？你说了一些关于他们获得世界上最大的 DGX 超级计算机集群之类的事情。是的，我昨晚发现了。总之，丹麦，我爱丹麦。老实说，它是我就最喜欢的斯堪的纳维亚国家吗？
I don't know. We have to spend some more time here. We'll be back. Number two per capita listeners of ADSP. We gave out some stickers. Some people have been tweeting about it. It's been fantastic. And yeah, any other things to say about Denmark before, I guess we should chat a little.
我不知道。我们必须在这里多花点时间。我们会回来的。ADSP 人均听众排名第二。我们分发了一些贴纸。有些人一直在推特上谈论它。这太棒了。是的，在我想我们应该聊聊之前，还有什么关于丹麦的话要说吗？
I'm trying to think about what my... favorite Scandinavian country is the thing is we've only really had one day
我正在努力思考我的……最喜欢的斯堪的纳维亚国家是什么，问题是我们真的只在这里待了一天。
here in Copenhagen so I don't think that I can really include Denmark in the rankings
在哥本哈根，所以我认为我真的不能把丹麦列入排名。
yet but I would have to say out of the ones that I've been to which would
目前，但我不得不说，在我去过的那些国家中，也就是。
be Finland Sweden and Norway and I think I've been to the capital I haven't been to Helsinki
芬兰、瑞典和挪威，我想我去过首都，我没去过赫尔辛基。
really but I think I got to go with Stockholm I got to go with Sweden I think is my favorite
真的，但我认为我得选斯德哥尔摩，我得选瑞典，我认为它是我的最爱。
it's stock home not Stackholm? I mean, this... What are you Texan? No on to this thing? Uh, yeah, why not?
是斯德哥尔摩（Stockholm）不是 Stackholm？我的意思是，这……你是德克萨斯人吗？不，关于这个？呃，是的，为什么不呢？
Okay. Well, if it ends with us in the water. We're going on a boat that is not a boat, but it looks like a boat. Yeah. Anyways, why Stockholm your favorite? And also, do you realize the blasphemy of you saying that Sweden is your favorite country of the Scandinavian countries while we're in Denmark? I'm just saying I have not had enough time to evaluate Copenhagen, but out of the ones that
好吧。嗯，如果它以我们在水里结束。我们要去坐一艘船，那不是一艘真正的船，但它看起来像一艘船。是的。总之，为什么斯德哥尔摩是你的最爱？还有，你意识到在丹麦说瑞典是你最喜欢的斯堪的纳维亚国家是一种亵渎吗？我只是说我没有足够的时间来评估哥本哈根，但在那些。
have had enough time to evaluate Stockholm. Um, there was a lot of history in Stockholm. It was also one of my first international trade. Maybe it's not a lot of history in Denmark. We've all heard of that famously. I have not had enough time here to evaluate. I really enjoyed the... I got to see the Vasa in Stockholm with, you know, the connection to C++, yeah.
我有足够时间评估的城市中，斯德哥尔摩。嗯，斯德哥尔摩有很多历史。这也是我第一次国际贸易之一。也许丹麦没有很多历史。我们都听说过那个著名的说法。我在这里没有足够的时间来评估。我真的很喜欢……我在斯德哥尔摩看到了瓦萨号（Vasa），你知道，它与 C++ 的联系，是的。
And, you know, very efficient train system. I really like to walk around the little, like, old market part of town. I just... It's... Yeah, a couple good meals. I just have fond memories of it It was one of my first trips I think that's probably why
而且，你知道，非常高效的火车系统。我真的很喜欢在城里那个小小的、像旧市场一样的地方走走。我只是……它是……是的，几顿美餐。我只是对它有美好的回忆，这是我的第一次旅行之一，我想这就是原因。
I just have fond memories of it Because it was one of my first trips For the Danish listeners That are currently listening to this podcast I do apologize once again On behalf of Bryce I would never say Such a blasphemous thing while in Denmark
我只是对它有美好的回忆，因为这是我的第一次旅行。对于目前正在收听本播客的丹麦听众，我再次代表布莱斯表示歉意。在丹麦，我绝不会说出如此亵渎的话。
And I would It's hard for me I mean I already know that I love Denmark And I think I love all the Scandinavian countries I've been to all four I've been to all four capitals I got to be honest, Norway is the frontrunner primarily because that's where I proposed to my fiancé
而且我会……这对我来说很难。我的意思是，我已经知道我爱丹麦，而且我认为我爱所有的斯堪的纳维亚国家。我去过所有四个。我去过所有四个首都。我得诚实地说，挪威是领跑者，主要是因为那是我向未婚妻求婚的地方。
and the Lofaten Islands in rain specifically for any Norwegian listeners. We do know that we have a lot of them. We do know we have a lot of them. We do. Norway, I think actually the rankings did get adjusted a little bit. I can't remember off the top of my head, but the Isle of Man,
在罗弗敦群岛（Lofaten Islands）的雨中，特别对任何挪威听众说。我们确实知道我们有很多挪威听众。我们确实知道我们有很多。我们确实有。挪威，我想排名确实稍微调整了一下。我记不清了，但马恩岛（Isle of Man），
due to its very low population and potentially one listener there or a traveler that is a listener from somewhere else, I think they're ranked number six And Finland drop below that I think Norway might be number five now Independent country though Is that a British
由于其人口非常少，可能只有一个听众，或者是一个来自其他地方的旅行者听众，我认为他们排名第六，芬兰跌到了那下面，我想挪威现在可能是第五名。不过是独立国家吗？那是英国的。
I believe it's a British protectorate Of some form I did see that there was Greenland Actually Registered as its own country On the platform that I'm The Isle of Man is a crown dependency So
我相信它是某种形式的英国保护国。我确实看到格陵兰岛实际上在平台上被注册为自己的国家。马恩岛是英国的皇家属地，所以。
No offense to the people Of the Isle of Man I'm just saying That it's separate front like you can't really judge it in comparison with say like Norway or Sweden which is a separate independent country but but the point uh that I'm about to make here is that we were questioning on the last recording two days ago on the way from orhus to Copenhagen that there was 205 countries and I did say that I thought there was 206 bones in the body and 194 plus or
对马恩岛的人没有冒犯的意思。我只是说它是分开的，就像你不能真正把它与挪威或瑞典这样的国家进行比较，后者是独立的国家，但我要说的重点是，我们在两天前从奥胡斯到哥本哈根的路上录音时质疑过，有 205 个国家，我确实说过我认为人体有 206 块骨头，194 加或。
minus depending on the count if it's UN plus or minus clearly they have one of these higher counts because Greenland is separate from Denmark aisle of man is separate from the UK um the rule the rule for this podcast has to be whether or not you have a whether or not you have a the rule for this podcast is whatever our platform so because our platform disambiguates
减，取决于计数，如果是联合国加或减，显然他们有更高的计数之一，因为格陵兰岛与丹麦分开，马恩岛与英国分开，嗯，这个播客的规则必须是关于你是否有一个，或者你是否有一个，这个播客的规则是我们的平台是什么，所以因为我们的平台区分了。
between Greenland and Denmark which might mean that Denmark if it included the Greenland listeners might be number one. Here let's get the Carlsberg in the show what are we doing? Clearly we will cut the silence out folks of Bryce taking a photo of me anyways I think Norway's
格陵兰岛和丹麦，这可能意味着如果丹麦包括格陵兰岛的听众，它可能是第一名。来，让我们把嘉士伯放进节目里，我们在做什么？显然我们会剪掉布莱斯给我拍照的沉默，伙计们，总之我认为挪威是。
the frontrunner also when we stayed at the hotel when I was at ND or we, my partner and I, when we were at NDC, Oslo, and when we were in Trondheim, almost all the places that had breakfast, they had multiple types of smoke salmon. I love seafood, and one of my favorite seafoods is smoke salmon. I grew up living off of it, and I've never had options, and the seafood in Norway is phenomenal. But I got to say, Finland has the saunas. Denmark is just absolutely gorgeous. I don't want to upset our Dutch listeners, and I am half Dutch.
领跑者，还有当我们住在酒店时，当我在 NDC 时，或者我们，我的伴侣和我，当我们在 NDC 奥斯陆时，以及当我们在特隆赫姆时，几乎所有提供早餐的地方，他们都有多种类型的烟熏三文鱼。我喜欢海鲜，我最喜欢的海鲜之一是烟熏三文鱼。我从小就靠它生活，我从来没有选择，挪威的海鲜非常棒。但我得说，芬兰有桑拿。丹麦绝对是华丽的。我不想让我们的荷兰听众不高兴，而且我是半个荷兰人。
So what I am going to say is definitely going to be more blasphemous. Actually, is it more blasphemous? I'm not sure. But if I have to compare the Netherlands and Denmark, Denmark might be in the lead. And the reason for this is because they're very similar, in my opinion, in that they're kind of built around and on the water. But the Netherlands, specifically Amsterdam, is chaotic. You're likely to die from a, I don't want to say a cyclist,
所以我接下来要说的话肯定会更亵渎。其实，这更亵渎吗？我不确定。但如果我必须比较荷兰和丹麦，丹麦可能会领先。原因在于，在我看来，它们非常相似，因为它们都是围绕水和在水上建造的。但荷兰，特别是阿姆斯特丹，是混乱的。你很可能会死于一个，我不想说是骑自行车的人。
I'm from a cohort of cyclists. I almost died multiple times. And it's just crazy. They do have much better birds. Denmark has a bit of a weak bird game. But running around today, it was just absolutely, the recommendations that I got from the folks at Symbian last night for where to run were absolutely amazing.
我来自一个骑行群体。我差点死过好几次。这太疯狂了。他们的鸟类确实好得多。丹麦的鸟类游戏有点弱。但今天跑来跑去，这绝对是，昨晚 Symbian 的伙伴们给我的跑步建议绝对太棒了。
Anyways, those are my hot takes. Bryce has been trying to say something, and he's been politely waiting. I'm going to hand the mic over to Bryce. Let's get Bryce's thoughts. I don't even know where to begin. There are so many ways in which you've been. so many countries in such a short period of time.
总之，这些是我的热门观点。布莱斯一直想说点什么，他一直在礼貌地等待。我要把麦克风交给布莱斯。让我们听听布莱斯的想法。我甚至不知道从哪里开始。你在这么短的时间内去了这么多国家。
Who did I think? Potentially the Dutch. Oh, I was going to say, I was going to say Norway. I love my time in Norway. However, it was very cold and very rainy, but we did have a wonderful time in Oslo and Bergen last year. And we're very excited. Very excited to be going back.
我以为是谁？可能是荷兰人。哦，我本来想说，我本来想说挪威。我喜欢在挪威的时光。然而，它非常冷，雨水很多，但去年我们在奥斯陆和卑尔根度过了一段美好的时光。我们非常兴奋。非常兴奋能回去。
Very excited to be going back. But I think we should talk about something technical. That's true. Well, I think we ought to talk about the thing we were talking about at dinner. Ah, we can't talk about that yet. Well, we can talk about it in the abstract, yeah? Uh, is there, is there even anything, is there even anything concrete, though, to hang on to there? Well, yeah, yeah, just describe, describe, and, and, you can't, we can't even say, you can't even say that?
非常兴奋能回去。但我认为我们应该谈谈技术方面的事情。那是真的。嗯，我认为我们应该谈谈我们在晚餐时谈论的事情。啊，我们还不能谈论那个。嗯，我们可以在抽象层面上谈论它，对吧？呃，有什么，有什么具体的东西可以挂钩吗？嗯，是的，是的，只要描述，描述，而且，你不能，我们甚至不能说，你甚至不能说那个？
I think you can describe the nature of the thing. Let's just wait, let's just wait three weeks, and then it'll be, this isn't going to be public, this isn't going to be poster through. No, that's not true. It'll be published in maybe two to three weeks. The problem is that I have an issue with, I guess we can talk about the example. I have, yeah, a library that is in the midst of being open-sourced. We'll be able to start talking about a lot more. Actually, we might be having a topic that we can switch to that I mentioned a couple episodes ago.
我认为你可以描述事物的本质。让我们等一下，让我们等三周，然后它就会，这不是要公开的，这不是要通过海报发布的。不，那不是真的。它将在两到三周内发布。问题是我有一个问题，我想我们可以谈谈这个例子。我有一个，是的，一个正在开源过程中的库。我们将能够开始谈论更多。其实，我们可能会有一个可以切换到的主题，我在几期节目前提过。
But the problem is that there's a problem that we don't actually know what the problem is. And so we spent half of dinner talking about solutions to the potential problem and realizing that what I thought was the source of the problem probably isn't the source of the problem. But we had an interesting conversation about lifetimes and ownership in these lazily evaluated frameworks that I think is... Too many details. I think it's fine. I think it's fine. I think it's pretty...
但问题是，有一个问题，我们实际上不知道问题是什么。所以我们花了半顿晚餐时间讨论潜在问题的解决方案，并意识到我以为是问题根源的东西可能不是问题的根源。但我们进行了一次关于这些惰性求值框架中生命周期和所有权的有趣对话，我认为这是……太多细节了。我认为没问题。我认为没问题。我认为它非常……
I don't think we're going to get in trouble for this. I don't think we're going to get in trouble for this. I don't know. I don't think. I don't know. We could just talk about replicate. So you just listened to her, you just heard a bunch of beeps, beeps. And so we'll be revisiting that.
我不认为我们会因此惹上麻烦。我不认为我们会因此惹上麻烦。我不知道。我不认为。我不知道。我们可以只谈论复制（replicate）。所以你刚才听到了，你刚才听到了一堆哔哔声。所以我们会重新审视那个。
Are we just going to sit here? We're going to chill here. We're going to chill here. All right. So there might be a little bit of background music from some party on the water, but hopefully you can't hear that too much. Replicate is a function from APL. And in the version that exists in APL, it's a binary function.
我们只是要坐在这里吗？我们要在这里放松。我们要在这里放松。好吧。所以水上某个派对可能会有一些背景音乐，但希望你听不到太多。Replicate 是 APL 中的一个函数。在 APL 的版本中，它是一个二元函数。
It takes two arguments, a sequence or an array. And the second argument is a what we will call index mask that corresponds, or it has the same length as the, original sequence or array and there's technically two overloads of this one of them the second argument is an index max the other one is just an integer so maybe we'll
它接受两个参数，一个序列或一个数组。第二个参数是我们称之为索引掩码的东西，它对应于，或者它与原始序列或数组具有相同的长度，并且技术上有两个重载，其中一个是第二个参数是索引掩码，另一个只是一个整数，所以也许我们会。
start with the integer version because that one's a little bit easier for me to wrap my head around always yes so we'll we're going to use for our source array a character array because it's going to be easier to keep track of the input so if your character
从整数版本开始，因为那个对我来说更容易理解，总是这样，是的，所以我们将使用字符数组作为我们的源数组，因为这样更容易跟踪输入，所以如果你的字符。
array is A, B, C and you call the overload that takes an integer so you're arguments are the string or the character array ABC and the number three, your resulting output is AAA B, B, B, C, C, C, C. So you replicate or you repeat every element and number of times. The other version, the overload that takes an index map, where I guess index map, we'll just call it an integer sequence that corresponds to the length of your character array or your array.
数组是 A, B, C，你调用接受整数的重载，所以你的参数是字符串或字符数组 ABC 和数字 3，你的输出结果是 AAA B, B, B, C, C, C, C。所以你复制或重复每个元素 n 次。另一个版本，接受索引映射的重载，我猜是索引映射，我们姑且称之为与你的字符数组或数组长度对应的整数序列。
We'll replicate or repeat each corresponding element, the number of times corresponding to that integer. So if you have ABC and one, two, three, your resulting sequence is A, B, B, C, C, C. So it's similar to a copy if, a stood copy if, or a thrust copy if, except that you can think of a copy if
我们将复制或重复每个对应的元素，次数对应于该整数。所以如果你有 ABC 和 1, 2, 3，你的结果序列是 A, B, B, C, C, C。所以它类似于复制，一个 std::copy_if，或一个 thrust::copy_if，除了你可以认为 copy_if。
as a specialization of replicate, where the maximum value of your integer is one. So it can just be zero and one. And actually, is that how you implement it? No, that's not how you implement it because you implemented it as an iterator. Yeah. So, I mean, what's interesting about this
是 replicate 的一种特例，其中你的整数的最大值是 1。所以它只能是 0 和 1。而且实际上，你是那样实现的吗？不，你不是那样实现的，因为你把它实现为一个迭代器。是的。所以，我的意思是，有趣的是。
is that, and there's a whole Arraycast episode that talks about the implementation of replicate and also the history of replicate is that the history of replicate was that it originally started as an algorithm or a primitive called compress, which was the same thing, but
这一点，而且有一个完整的 Arraycast 剧集讨论了 replicate 的实现以及 replicate 的历史，那就是 replicate 的历史是它最初作为一个算法或原语开始，称为压缩（compress），它是同样的事情，但是。
instead of an integer sequence, it only took a mask of truths and falses, so ones and zeros. So it is, in that specialization, it is identical to copy-if. Basically, you are doing a filter or a compaction where you drop all the elements or characters corresponding to a zero
它不是整数序列，它只接受一个真值和假值的掩码，也就是 1 和 0。所以它是，在那个特例中，它等同于 copy_if。基本上，你是在做一个过滤或压缩，你丢弃所有对应于 0 的元素或字符。
and you copy the ones corresponding to a one, which is essentially copy if except that copy if, I mean there's multiple overloads in the thrust library, but the standard copy if, it just takes a predicate. So it keeps the ones that return true for a predicate. But in thrust, you have the overload that we talk about a lot, the stencil overload where you can pass at a sequence that anything that evaluates to a true is kept. Bryce has a question or a comment or a thought. Yeah, the commonwealth press makes me think, is there a relation to replicate, in particular the second overload and run-length encoding?
你复制对应于 1 的那些，这本质上就是 copy_if，除了 copy_if，我的意思是 thrust 库中有多个重载，但标准的 copy_if，它只接受一个谓词。所以它保留那些为谓词返回 true 的元素。但在 thrust 中，你有我们经常谈论的重载，模板重载，你可以传递一个序列，任何评估为 true 的东西都会被保留。布莱斯有一个问题或评论或想法。是的，英联邦出版社让我思考，是否存在一种与 replicate 相关的关系，特别是第二个重载和游程编码？
Yes, absolutely. So run-length encode, or it's actually run-length decoding. But so run-length encoding and decoding, for those that are not familiar with the algorithm, it basically turns your sequence where we had A, B, B, C-C-C, if you run-length encode that, you turn that into, I mean, there's multiple ways you can do it. It turns it into the iterator construct, basically.
是的，绝对是。所以游程编码，或者实际上是游程解码。但是，所以游程编码和解码，对于那些不熟悉该算法的人来说，它基本上把你的序列，我们有 A, B, B, C-C-C，如果你对它进行游程编码，你把它变成，我的意思是，有多种方法可以做到。它把它变成迭代器构造，基本上。
It turns it in. Run lengthen code would take the expanded sequence and turn it into the compressed form that you could express with this replicate function. And most libraries that have a run lengthen code, the output will be an array of pairs or key value pairs or a dictionary or something like that. Or not usually a dictionary because that can be unordered.
它把它变成。游程编码会获取扩展的序列并将其转换为你可以用这个 replicate 函数表达的压缩形式。大多数拥有游程编码的库，输出将是成对的数组或键值对或字典之类的东西。或者通常不是字典，因为那可能是无序的。
So the A, B, CCC, it ends up as 1A, 2B, 3C, and those are usually stored as either, you know, subarrays of length 2 or pairs, whereas replicate, you know, it passes these as separate sequences as arguments to the function. But the point being is that you asked, does run length encoding, but what you meant was decoding have a relationship, is that the decoding of a run length encoding is basically, you know, morally. equivalent to a replicate because replicate just takes the sequence and the integers that you're expanding whereas a run length decoding you know actually i don't actually know what a run length decode what that API is but usually it'll unpack the pairs and then like do the decoding that way do you uh okay so this this brings us nicely to the next topic i wanted to get to which is um uh there's a couple separate questions here um the first one is uh do you implement the so the There's two forms of the replicate.
所以 A, B, CCC，它最终变成 1A, 2B, 3C，这些通常存储为长度为 2 的子数组或对，而 replicate，你知道，它将这些作为单独的序列作为参数传递给函数。但重点是你问，游程编码，但你指的是解码是否有关系，是游程解码基本上，你知道，在道德上。等同于 replicate，因为 replicate 只是获取序列和你要扩展的整数，而游程解码，你知道，其实我不知道游程解码的 API 是什么，但通常它会解包这些对，然后像那样进行解码，你，呃，好吧，这很好地引出了我想谈的下一个话题，也就是，呃，这里有几个单独的问题，第一个是，呃，你是否实现了，所以有两种形式的 replicate。
There's the one that takes the array, and it's the one that takes the engineer. Do you implement the one that takes the array of replication lengths? Do you implement that with run-length decoding? And if not, that's the thing that you ought to think about, because we have an optimized version of that in Cub. And I don't, so I know that run-length encoding and run-length decoding is commonly used in image processing and in like compression and decompression. I don't know the exact specifics of how exactly it's used, but I do know that there are tricks to implement it very efficiently.
有一种接受数组的，还有一种接受整数的。你是否实现了接受复制长度数组的那种？你是否用游程解码实现了它？如果不是，那是你应该考虑的事情，因为我们在 Cub 中有一个优化版本。而且我不知道，所以我知道游程编码和游程解码通常用于图像处理和压缩与解压缩。我不知道它具体是如何使用的确切细节，但我确实知道有一些技巧可以非常有效地实现它。
And my second question is, in your current implementation today, how do you implement it? And do you implement the case of the replicate within differently than the replicate with, you know, different length for each input? Because I imagine that there are, you know, if you know that you're always replicating, you know, the same, for every element, the same number of times, I imagine that you can do more efficient things. So maybe you can comment about how you implement your replica. And we should say we've been describing replicate as a function, but the replicate we were talking about earlier was really the implementation of that through a replicate iterator.
我的第二个问题是，在你今天当前的实现中，你是如何实现的？你是否以不同于 replicate 的方式实现 replicate 的情况，你知道，每个输入有不同的长度？因为我想象，你知道，如果你知道你总是复制，你知道，对于每个元素，相同的次数，我想象你可以做更有效的事情。所以也许你可以评论一下你是如何实现你的 replicate 的。我们应该说我们一直把 replicate 描述为一个函数，但我们之前谈论的 replicate 实际上是通过 replicate 迭代器实现的。
So first of all, when referring to the two overloads, let's say integer and the array overloads, because when you said N, I thought you said in. And so if I didn't hear what you said, the listener might be confused. So for the integer over, and wait, to answer your first, question, I do not use, first of all, I don't implement, well, actually, so now we're going back to talking about the library that we shouldn't be talking about. It's okay.
所以首先，当提到两个重载时，让我们说整数和数组重载，因为当你说是 N 时，我以为你说的是 in。所以如果我没听清你说什么，听众可能会感到困惑。所以对于整数重载，等等，回答你的第一个问题，我不使用，首先，我不实现，嗯，其实，所以现在我们回到谈论我们不应该谈论的库。没关系。
It's okay to talk about the library. I don't implement. I do have a run-length encoding. It does not use Cub. It uses a thrust implementation that relies on reduced by key. And I don't have run-length decoding as a method. And also, I do not use the cub run-length encoding or decoding in any of this replicate stuff.
谈论这个库没关系。我不实现。我确实有一个游程编码。它不使用 Cub。它使用依赖于 reduced_by_key 的 thrust 实现。我没有游程解码作为方法。而且，我也没有在任何这些 replicate 的东西中使用 cub 游程编码或解码。
It's all thrust-based. I know for certain Cub has a run-length in code, which you should definitely be using. Maybe you can comment about why you're not. I'm not certain if it has a run-length decode, though. So, yeah, that's interesting. I'm not using it because there are only one or two functions that rely on Cub directly,
它完全是基于 thrust 的。我知道 Cub 肯定有一个游程编码，你绝对应该使用它。也许你可以评论一下为什么你没有使用。不过我不确定它是否有游程解码。所以，是的，这很有趣。我没有使用它，因为只有一两个函数直接依赖于 Cub，
because it's something that I only started adding at the very tail end of the work that I've been doing. Now that you mention it, it'd be very easy to just direct. rely on that, especially if it's specialized. So then how do you implement these two overloads today? I mean, so that is the topic of this episode. It's for me to ask you, how would you implement? Because when I was implementing this, I think actually the first way that I approached
因为这是我直到我所做工作的最后阶段才开始添加的东西。既然你提到了，直接依赖它会非常容易，特别是如果它是专门化的。那么你今天是如何实现这两个重载的呢？我的意思是，这就是本期节目的主题。让我问你，你会如何实现？因为当我实现这个时，我想其实我最初尝试的方法。
it didn't end up working. And I ended up having to switch. And I'm actually going to have to pull up the code while you talk through how you think. So, I mean, I can actually, the integer one, is less interesting because the integer one I just do lazily and I definitely know
最终没有奏效。我不得不切换。而且在你谈论你的想法时，我实际上不得不调出代码。所以，我的意思是，我实际上可以，整数那个，不太有趣，因为整数那个我只是懒惰地做，而且我绝对知道。
that the initial implementation was just an invocation of the thrust fancy iterator the permutation iterator because a permutation iterator basically just takes some mapping oh I see we are at a
最初的实现只是对 thrust 奇特迭代器（fancy iterator）排列迭代器（permutation iterator）的调用，因为排列迭代器基本上只是获取某种映射，哦，我明白了，我们在一个。
ferry stop we might stop talking for a while We probably should go walk somewhere else No, I think it's fine We're just going to pause here for a few minutes While this ferry docks and undocks Should we take the ferry? No
渡轮站，我们可能会停止说话一段时间，我们可能应该去别的地方走走，不，我认为没问题，我们只是要在这里暂停几分钟，当这艘渡轮停靠和离开时，我们应该坐渡轮吗？不。
Well, why not? I don't know where this fairy goes Well, that's the fun part For all we know, this ferry goes on like a two-hour loop And we're not going to be back here for two hours I mean, it could also go to, like, go to, like, Norway or something. Maybe we'll get there early. This is, this ferry is not a large boat, I would say.
嗯，为什么不呢？我不知道这艘渡轮去哪里，嗯，那是乐趣所在，据我们所知，这艘渡轮走的是两小时的环线，我们两小时内不会回到这里，我的意思是，它也可能去，比如，去，比如，挪威之类的。也许我们会早点到那里。这，这艘渡轮不是一艘大船，我会说。
It's, uh, and maybe holds, like, 20 or 30 people. So it's pretty clear that it is a local ferry. I'm going to take a picture for, for the listener. We'll put it on the social media. Oh, wow. That was, that was quick. We didn't even have a chance to get on that fair. The ferry's gone.
它，呃，也许能容纳，比如，20 或 30 人。所以很明显它是一艘当地的渡轮。我要给听众拍张照片。我们会把它放在社交媒体上。哦，哇。那，那很快。我们甚至没有机会上那艘渡轮。渡轮走了。
That sucker, look at how fast that thing's going. And for any of the very, um, For the avid listener that has referenced the photo online that Bryce will tweet and his saying that this only seats 20 to 30 people, his estimation abilities are wildly off. I would say this easily sits 100, maybe more. Okay, maybe it is more like that. I see ferries in Vancouver that are a fraction. I'm talking like a tenth the size of this that can pack in 20 easily. That's, you know, with standing room, that ferry can fit 200.
那个混蛋，看看那东西走得有多快。对于任何非常，嗯，对于引用布莱斯将在推特上发布的照片的狂热听众，他说这只能坐 20 到 30 人，他的估计能力完全偏离了。我会说这很容易坐 100 人，也许更多。好吧，也许更像那样。我在温哥华看到的渡轮只有一小部分。我说的是十分之一的大小，可以轻松装下 20 人。那是，你知道，有站立空间，那艘渡轮可以容纳 200 人。
I said seat, though, to be fair. I did not say including standing room. Well, yeah, well, wow, well. Anyways, we're going to hand the mic back. We were talking about, so the integer overload, lazily done. I think the initial implementation was with a permutation iterator, and then I... Can you elaborate on that? So a permutation iterator, for instance, in the simplest case, if we go back to our original sequence of ABC,
但我说的是座位，公平地说。我没有说包括站立空间。嗯，是的，嗯，哇，嗯。总之，我们要把麦克风交回去。我们刚才在谈论，所以整数重载，懒惰地完成。我想最初的实现是用排列迭代器，然后我……你能详细说明一下吗？所以排列迭代器，例如，在最简单的情况下，如果我们回到我们最初的 ABC 序列，
we can give it a sequence, I believe it is, of indices in whatever order you want. And it's basically the equivalent of a scatter iterator. Why do they call it a permutation iterator? Nobody knows. We'd have to ask Nathan or Jared, the two authors of Thrust. but the same way that sequence the algorithm does not correspond to the iterator version which is the counting iterator
我们可以给它一个序列，我相信是，以你想要的任何顺序的索引。它基本上等同于散点迭代器（scatter iterator）。为什么他们称它为排列迭代器？没人知道。我们得问问 Nathan 或 Jared，Thrust 的两位作者。但同样的方式，序列算法并不对应于迭代器版本，也就是计数迭代器（counting iterator）。
in my mental model is that scatter is the algorithm and scatter is an algorithm I see there another one is here all right moving no it's fine it's fine nobody has indicated that they're upset with us being here I mean fine we can move you finish there's another spot over there though
在我的心理模型中，scatter 是算法，scatter 是一个算法，我看到另一个在这里，好吧，移动，不，没关系，没关系，没有人表示他们对我们在这里感到不满。我的意思是，好吧，我们可以移动，你完成，那边还有另一个点。
okay fine I don't know you kind of's being very Canadian about the fact that we're at a ferry terminal. It's a very stop, not a terminal. There was a giant spider above your head. Really? Yeah. So I don't mind moving.
好吧，没关系，我不知道你对我们在渡轮码头这件事表现得非常加拿大。这是一个渡轮站，不是终点站。你头顶上有一只巨大的蜘蛛。真的吗？是的。所以我不在乎移动。
That's the only reason I agreed. So, okay, so sorry, you're going to have to restart your explanation. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity.
这是我同意的唯一原因。所以，好吧，所以抱歉，你将不得不重新开始你的解释。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。
That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。